you
welcome dr. very much
the astrazeneca naw gurl medicine
initiative is important we demonstrate
the commitment of both sides to really
help to disseminate the information
about those important scientific
discoveries after we discovered
Helicobacter and suggested that this
bacterium could be the cause of ulcers
nobody believed us and nobody wanted to
start treating ulcers with antibiotics
dr. Marshall shows the passion and his
innovation for science he gets himself
in factors by drinking the bacteria
liquid so here I am drinking the
helicobacter of my lab techniques is dr.
Marshall you're crazy and I'm saying
there's no other way we want to inspire
students and researchers to further
their efforts and be excited about
pursuing careers in research I was
curious about when Professor water first
came to you with his hypothesis did you
also doubt about that he wanted to her
connect with patients so dr. Warren
taught me everything I know about
histology and showed me those bacteria
and I said you know I can see it with my
own eyes I believe it so I don't care
what anyone else says that was so
exciting as like daydreaming I never
dreamed about that I could have a chance
to talk to the Nobel Prize winner it is
very important for our science to hear
and feel the passion from the maternal
rates to feel how they against all the
odds that really believe what they think
is about saying and pursue that being
that idea so I submitted my paper for a
local meeting this is my rejection later
dr. Marshall or regret your research
plate was not accepted for presentation
that i'm sure is very expiring inspiring
to our yard scientists as well and if
they really believe it is they should do
whatever you can to either prove it or
disapprove it when you get a rejection
letter keep it and so many years later
if you are correct you still have your
rejection later and you can share woody
well there are many inspirational
moments over from Professor Marshalls
talk one of our young scientists asked
about his advice for people like him who
are still early in his career he might
sites in advance
to be young because you have an open
mind you don't have any fixed beliefs
and so you lack the knowledge but you're
ready to take new knowledge and very
inspired by professor marshals and story
it's a good opportunity to have this
chance to talk to such a famous
personally and such a close distance
professor Marshall just asked us to do
what you are interested in at the doings
and maybe you'll get something very
surprising Ellis broaden our horizon and
let us see the world outside and see
what the top scientists are thinking
about follow your heart and do the
research that you're interested in like
his words ever worries Barry and that I
want to share with my friends about
story so I come it's kind of a
experience of a lifetime to have sugar
you have a Nobel laureate to come over
and give a talk
you